we're also taking more theme songs for
whose stats get give us a sample here
maybe Darius Rucker would like to give
us a who's task give me one there uh
yeah so this is it we're looking for
more theme songs here who stats would
you want huh you can leave your stats
behind and if you have no stats well now
you've got stats and uh those stats are
mine give me one more and then we'll get
to Darius another great singer we bring
in Darius Rucker what do you think those
who were awesome that's like a guy who I
will do is doing I will always love you
part that was thank you thank you okay
so you wake up this morning and what do
you think now because yesterday you were
at the garden you watched it but you
wake up and what do you think I can't
really didn't wanna go to sleep tonight
away what was the celebration like oh oh
man you know it was awesome I was
sitting there and I'm you know I'm
freaking out I'm there with my boy and
they come and go hey man you want to go
on the court of course I want to go on
the court you know and to be out there
watch them cut down the net and it was
so funny
I saw somebody you know videos of stuff
of me getting a little most no and I was
like I'm so glad no when he saw me
talking to coach Brook coach mark
because we were both free but losing it
but I it was great great but it's not
done yet man we'll be celebrating Felix
why so emotional I've been following
Gamecocks sports for 40 years man I've
been a big fan and and we've gotten to
bring so many time my freshman year in
college we get to number two in the
catching a football it lose to Navy by
35 you know and then we got we got a
great basketball team in the 90s you get
the number two seed we lose the coffin
state the first pile you know and uh
that's our game constantly and I was
there at flavors at the beginning of the
game I'm there with my son and I'm just
so excited cuz I'm looking around going
console playing the cartilage chance to
go to the floor you know it's just it
was so Moses for me I was like this is
not I said I'm just so I was so happy
for bright for Coach Martin so happy
because he came to school and you know
there would there's always the loud
naysayers or like he's not gonna turn
around I'm like here we are one of the
Final Four man I was just although I was
over overcome with joy you probably
would have just taken the win over Duke
and be done with it you'd been fine
middle I saw your uh your tour manager
Mike Kelly sent a picture of you you're
on stage on Friday night and you had TV
monitors there so you could do your
concert and watch the Gamecocks play
yeah right in front of being mark we had
these TV to TV so the whole band can
watch the game and uh it was crazy but I
want to tell you that wasn't our idea in
the middle 80s the middle 80s
the Red Hot Chili Peppers were playing a
small club that we used to play called
Rockefeller in Columbia and we went to
see the show and the Lakers were playing
in the playoffs and they havethey they
wouldn't go on without a TV on the stage
are you going to the Final Four
oh yeah I'll be there I mean it's a
teams weekend but I think I've already
decided I'm definitely gonna be that
bullet a yeah I'll be there for sure no
how could I miss that oh you can what if
you had a show what if you had a concert
on Saturday um it would probably it
would probably be the first concert I
ever cancelled my locks I'll postpone to
my life yeah I have to
you never yeah never
there's never in my career have I
postponed or canceled the show that
wasn't weather-related you know I mean
like you know hurricane or someone we
can't play but I would have yeah I'd
have to go to that game a niche game
clock basketball I don't know if you
heard fritzy he thought the Gamecocks
were a dragon city about the people who
texted me dude it's an ass-kicking
chicken is what a game conquers all
right
this is what happens we'll say stuff
before the show starts and then we
realize it's good content so we didn't
correct fritzy we just thought we would
work it out on the air and fritz he said
that he thought it was a dragon and then
that's when Twitter kind of roughed him
up a little bit here yeah and they
should man this again where's Lana for
you you're on a sports program so I like
it were the first at various point of
view will you write a song about the
game Congress and we won the
championship I have no choice I truly
have no choice if we win a championship
actually right now I probably don't have
a choice you know but uh yeah I'm pretty
sure I don't know if it'll make a record
cuz it might suck what rhymes with sin
Darius Thornwell Frank Martin you can
you can do something with that but
absolutely i mean i got the i can i get
the feeling you're gonna have to write
something here I do like you know for
people who watch house battle as long as
we have their this reminds me of NC
State's but or where you're like you
know I don't believe in and you're
watching this team and you realize and
the thing you have to realize about the
game comes in the second half while
we're playing defense
what's in the best basketball in the
whole tournament when our defense is
shut it's just a great thing to be a
part over to watch man I love it what
was your grade point average in South
Carolina the first semester it was I
think three eight five and then I met my
buddies on the hall and it drop to about
a two four so your grade point average
was similar to Lavar balls scoring
average at Washington State exactly good
guys that's uptown Awards at that time a
party school we took full advantage of
that but now it's a really University
with us what if you didn't some great
faculty what if you didn't go to South
Carolina come on you know the funny oh I
would be bartending right now
I figured be totally different you know
it's funny to me because I was going to
Georgia's Clemson or South Carolina and
uh a Playboy magazine did this did this
top 25 40 schools I'm a barback wrote
the article top 25 party schools and at
the very end of the article or the last
paragraph said you're probably wondering
why I didn't include South University
South Carolina in this articles because
I don't include professional amateur all
right I need you do what I need you to
work on a whose stats would you want I
will I'm gonna listen to those or not
and I liked mom or God will come up with
a really good one I'm gonna cut it and
also if South Carolina wins will you
then sing I need you to sing one shining
moment on our show Straight Outta
Compton safe travels to Phoenix there
and good luck I didn't know you were the
game when i text you cuz I said are you
nervous in the final minute and then I
realized you were at the game so yeah I
think I surprised you a little bit there
you did what I congratulate Darius they
you guys win and then I congratulate you
and then I don't hear from you until the
next morning and I said I don't care
about South Carolina more it took you
too long to get back to me and you go
okay too drunk to get back to I'll talk
to you soon alright Matt Stairs wrecker
country star hooting the Blowfish and I
saw these web sites it was like who DS
crying at the game and Darius hates when
he's called Hootie cuz like I remember
going to those shows 20 years ago and
they go who D and then he'd be like and
I said don't you understand you created
a band where hoody and then the Blowfish
are the backups like you did it
don't blame us hoody the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience